hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and ah
just checking in on you
I'm just checking in to see how your
week's going
huh it's Thursday
back in the day I remember when I had
the old [__] nine to five that was
payday if I remember correctly Thursday
[__] scraping nickels together by
Tuesday flat broke on Wednesday Brown
bagging you lunch and then Thursday came
and then there was another 260 bucks
that's what I made full time 260
for unloading trucks laughing my ass off
still one of the great jobs I've ever
had right up there with stand-up comedy
working in a warehouse not married no
kids no credit
you know just acting like a [__]
idiot
shaking off a night of drinking
and late night McDonald's like it never
even happened just waking up with a flat
stomach
you know
a back that wasn't out
just going over just [__] bending
over at the waist picking up heavy [__]
not lifting with my legs
you know not stretching and then just
going to play softball after with
everybody else getting [__] hammered
wine coolers back in the 80s bottles and
James
they were sort of like the original
white cloth I don't even know what a
white Claw is white claw came out after
um my drinking days were over I was out
of the league
you know
speak speaking of which every year you
got to bring it up in baseball the
greatest contract ever signed the Bobby
Bonilla Bobby Bonilla Day July 1st New
York Mets pay him one point one nine
million dollars right through 2035
you know
tell you there's a guy who doesn't have
to worry about should I get Bitcoin or
not he doesn't give a [__]
gets a whole sack of money
man he's got to live in like Florida
he's got to be in one of those no no uh
no state taxes
[__] [__]
just out of curiosity before there was
before they did tax your income like how
did they pay for all this [__]
and how do we get back to that can you
imagine if you get to keep your whole
[__] check
I mean
just imagine
the fun you would have that extra
[__] couple hundred bucks every week
just imagine the fun you would have not
saving that either blowing that scraping
nickels together on Tuesday in brown
bagging it on Wednesday you could have
an extra [__] two to three hundred
dollars of fun
whatever the hell it was whatever you
make I don't know what the hell you make
um
man those were the days
I was smart enough to not um
I had a I did have a car payment and
when I paid that thing off I remember
like I just didn't like it I didn't like
Owen people money
and some of the guys that I worked with
would go out and go buy new cars
um
you know uh which part of me wishes I
did but I mean I didn't know where my
life was going I just I just knew I
sucked at everything
I sucked at everything that had to do
with school and school
the way it was sold to me was your
ticket to being successful like if you
were bad at school that was it you know
you'd see the kids that were in honors
classes
top of the class and just thinking like
oh man that guy's gonna be driving down
the street no Rolls-Royce convertible
chomping on a big cigar
you know
and I was you know going to summer
school hanging with all the [__] you
know class clowns Meatheads musicians
drug addicts
I want to say most of us in summer
school ended up in sales because
everybody was [__] hilarious and you
just I don't know I just wanted to be
around them they were a lot more fun
than the honors class not saying all the
honors class kids were Eggheads but for
the most part they were definitely uh
introverted
you know and I was like well I already
suck at school
you know
am I gonna suck quietly
or can I hang with these Knuckleheads
and laugh at least laugh my ass off
rather than sitting here uh acting like
I'm thinking when I'm not
um
anyway but if I could go back if I could
go back in time
and chain myself to my day job and not
have uh
and not have any uh you know options
financially at that point I would have I
would have traded I would have upgraded
my truck
I think I would have I think I probably
would have gotten the Ford Ranger 4x4
that one of the guys I worked with had
with the nice [__] rims and the big
tires in a [__] roll bar
you know
in some neon green
Risky Business Shades and that would
have been it
me and my [__]
orange head of hair coming down the
street listening to [__] AC DC in a
four by four
clearing out a new [__] place to
drink
that's what would happen back in the day
but not not old conservative film
not all I don't know about that
I kept my four cylinder no air
conditioning black vinyl [__] seats
[__]
fire engine red where
ended up having an engine fire on the
thing I've told you guys these stories
before
um
anyway
I'm still waiting for my [__] I'm
gonna [__] text the guy today are you
guys gonna [__] build the thing
are you guys gonna build that truck I
have no use for
but makes my ego feel good for a week
and then I'll be like why did I buy this
and then I'll sell it like what what
what what the [__] is taking so long
they told me January of February or
February that's what the Ford Motor
Company told me
any
news
on my
truck
being
assembled
[__] club soda Kenny got me all
freaked out
he goes to haven't built it yet
they're going to be coming out with the
2024s
every once in a while I get I get Club
sodas [__] he's so stoic
so every once in a while like I'll just
say something and it's so hard because
he he knows when I'm [__] with them
but the other day uh
I was in New York
and uh
I was getting ready to go over to The
Cellar and then go see that [__]
amazing band
uh the Yusuf days experience so he gives
me my plane ticket he goes here's your
plane ticket this is a hard copy of the
plane ticket
so you have it on you so you know
because he wasn't giving me a ride to
the airport
so I was like all right no worries I go
let me just go upstairs and I had to
grab my cell phone charger or something
so I know he's watching me so I turned
towards the hotel and I deliberately
stick the ticket light in my back pocket
it just falls down to the sidewalk and I
just hear like 10 feet away just go
and I just burst it out laughing and
then he knew that I got him and he just
started two times he's ever all the
years I've been working with them
once that time he called me an idiot and
there was one other time he called me a
jerk off and it was for whatever reason
I I overslept and I was sleeping really
hard and he was knocking on my hotel
room door and
I didn't answer and I always answer so
he's already thinking like there has to
be a problem he thought there was
something medically wrong with me and
then when they were banging them they
got he got security downstairs to open
my hotel door and I had the deadbolt
thing on we can just open the door a
little and they were yelling into the
room and he was convinced that I had had
like a heart attack or something and I
got up and I was just like oh sorry I
overslept and everything and then he was
kind of quiet
and we were standing at the like the
elevators and he just goes
next time set your alarm
[__] jerk off
[Laughter]
I started cracking up I'm like oh you
care
you [__] care about me
so anyway
I'll be seeing that big dummy this
weekend when I go out there to uh
College Station doing a show out there
with uh Dean Del Rey and then we're
gonna uh
we've got a day off and then we're gonna
head over to uh Austin Texas
and uh check out the Moto GP race which
I can't [__] believe I'm going to
that I'm so [__] excited
um and with that
let's talk a little bit of sports here
Red Sox lose again to The Undefeated
Tampa Bay Devil Rays
all right I know you're supposed to just
call them the Rays but there's no way at
11-0 they haven't signed a deal with the
devils with the Devil
um they are 11-0 and tonight we have
Chris Sale
back
he had a start it went well I believe he
got the win no flat screen TVs were hurt
during his start or afterward in the
clubhouse
so Chris here Chris Hale Chris Sale is
on the hill
he's on the bump
he's on the dirt nipple sorry I ran out
of sports
[__]
nicknames for the mound what do they
call it the mound the hill the bump
they do not call it the dirt nipple
um
although I will tell you having thrown
out a pitch at a major league ballpark
yes I did I'm throwing that in your face
I took it out of my back pocket you were
looking at your phone you didn't see it
coming I took it out and I threw it
right in your face I was surprised at
how low to the ground it was
I felt like I was maybe two inches off
the ground
[Music]
um
anyway
uh Chris Sale is on the mound tonight
I'm going to be Taping that game I
[__] love baseball
I really do
um and then I'm also obviously excited
about the NHL playoffs
and I love that the Bruins had the run
that they did because I knew that the
Canadians won 76 77 78 79 obviously
but I missed all of that like I didn't
start watching hockey till about 81.
and um so it was all about the Islanders
in Edmonton trying to Edmonton coming up
right
but I had no idea that the the uh gaudy
record
that those Larry Robinson gay leflore
Ken Dryden
those great Montreal teams put up I mean
they [__] won like that's one of
those like 80 games
and I don't think that there weren't
like any ties back then I think I don't
think they had like overtime
but like they had like
I should look it up I just don't feel
like looking it up but they had like out
of those four years like three game
three years they won at least 60 games
um they were essentially unfucking
beatable
um so it's pretty cool when somebody
does something like what the Bruins are
doing and then you end up learning some
more stuff about the past which I think
is great
um
so we shall see I mean just because you
have a gaudy regular season record
everybody goes back to zero and zero and
then you had then you have the pressure
of the playoffs so we shall see
um oh another 80s movie that I watched
that I highly [__] recommend I
watched uh Eddie Murphy and Nick Nolte
in one of my favorite Eddie Murphy
movies ever
um 48 hours
and um to this day I still wish somebody
would write a script
that um has the tone of that movie for
Eddie I always love that because
it was perfect it was it's funny you
know
it's like oh I guess you know obviously
the clumps and coming to America and
Beverly Hills Cop those were more geared
towards comedy but I loved about 48
Hours was it was it was a real movie
like it had tense moments and all of
that and people getting [__] you know
their heads blown off and [__] and then
Eddie was hilarious and Nick Nolte with
Eddie was a great
you know cop buddy movie but I will tell
you man the level of [__] racist [__]
that Nolte's character says to Eddie
Murphy's kids just like Jesus Christ
and that was like a thing
back then
um as far as uh
I noticed like whenever whenever they
had that thing where all of a sudden in
the late 60s you could start swearing in
movies or cursing as the kids say
and you could show titties
and all of that [__] and they started
getting the rating system and all that
like
um from like the late 60s
until somewhere like in like the 84-85
like the like any cop any tough guy in
any movie it seemed like they were gonna
drop the n-word
they were gonna they were just gonna go
right down the list but if you look at
it like everything was so [__] like
Beyond
like race it was also like ethnicity
where even like white people would be
like to each other
be like hey let me tell you grease ball
something if one more Pollock comes over
here I'm gonna I'm gonna [__] you
know
beat you to death with this mcfucking
frog Crouch son of a [__] like
it's just [__]
you gotta like it's still a great movie
48 hours but like there's a couple where
it's like all right I get it
I get it
and then at one point that's just a
scene at the bar and Nolte's just his
characters just like yeah listen to my
I'm sorry about all that watermelon
n-word stuff
it's just doing my job it's just keeping
you down
and then Eddie's character is like yeah
well you know that doesn't explain
everything and then
Jack Cates is just like yeah I know
and then Eddie just goes
that explained that old part of the
movie away
um
but other than that I would say uh James
Remar and uh
um oh I gotta I gotta get Billy bear
that actor just passed away
unfortunately
um the two of them
playing the bad guys
and then the dude who played Luther and
what's cool is James Remar and the dude
who played Luther were both in the
Warriors
um
hang on
I'm gonna get better at this we'll
actually have all of this stuff at my
fingertips
so everybody thinks that I actually know
everybody's name in the [__] movie
which I'm always amazing people can do
that oh like those DJs you know that
like the Jazz album
you know and then they just name
everybody
on the [__] thing they're just like
uh that was uh Miles Davis and the
trumpet John Coltrane on the saxophone
and like 20 minutes later they're just
like that was uh Eddie Rabinowitz on the
xylophone
Eddie Rabinowitz Jr on The Vibes
on Timothy timpani we had Carl Porter
the great Carl Porter
um
who as many of know played the uh
triangle on 4G and Bess
a great album
um that was off the Blue Note label I
believe
was it yes it was the Blue Note label
you know listen to a jazz [__] radio
station it's like
like most of the hour is the [__] DJ
telling you who played on what it's like
how would you play another song you
[__] [__]
um
and on the didgeridoo that of course was
Peter
Peter Remar Peter Remar on the
didgeridoo
taking a solo that was A3 against four
Motif with a bit of the club clavier
Cuban afro-cuban style
68 degrees out another wonderful
his Springtime sort of okay sunny
landham
Sunny Lanta as Billy bear he recently
passed away David Patrick Kelly as
Luther
um
and then of course it's you know I
always loved Kehoe
Brian James he passed away inspector Ben
Kehoe it just sucks in the second one
when they make him a dirty cop
you know ah it's like not Kehoe
um
anyway
and then who's the ex-football player
that's just screaming oh even even he
calls Eddie the n-word
he's like
he's screaming at him for some n-word
conflict that's right I called him an
n-word you bet I did
foreign
The Writer's room it was all white guys
over 50. that's what I'm going to guess
on that one but still a [__] great
movie
um other than that [__] and then you get
the bus boys that actually ended up
going out on tour with Eddie Murphy
Eddie had a lot I think he had a lot of
musicians open up for him I'm gonna
guess because I saw him on the raw tour
and he had the weather girls
open up singing It's Raining Men
Hallelujah number Eddie coming out you
know joking around making sure like the
stage because they were both big girls
said the weather girls can [__] up a
stage I do remember that
um so anyway uh definitely check that
one out
um
there's got to be a sketch out there
where they just make fun of like
how overtly [__] racist like every
[__] cop and tough guy was in any of
those like like James Khan Thief
I'm just thinking of all those movies
that I recently watched I think blowout
was like that
48 Hours was like that Serpico
um I haven't said that they're all
[__] great movies but um
anyway
this is nature
I feel like I'm doing that with these
things it's like Bill we know all right
uh I went flying yesterday
with my instructor
this is a brilliant my instructor is
um
I have a little four-wheeler that we tow
the helicopter out with and uh the idol
needs to be it's it's idling too low so
it kind of goes like
and I was saying to him I was like you
know Alex Van Halen
came up for Hot for Teacher listening to
like a hot rod idling that's how he came
up with that
you know
and he's like oh that's like really cool
so he recorded it
and just in the morning just wrote a
[__] song around it
Randy Waldman is his name the great
Randy Waldman
um
who spent his first gig I'll give him a
little shout out his first gig at 18 was
he was the piano player
for Frank Sinatra
and since then he's gone on to be George
Benson and Barbra Streisand's musical
director and also he's an incredible
helicopter pilot so I get to fly with
him
and uh we ended up doing the
um
what is it the uh the harbor transition
through lax's airspace where you're at
900 feet or below so there's three
places where you can cut
across lax's airspace when all those big
boys are landing there's uh the 110
Harbor Freeway
uh which is really cool because you're
right at downtown LA at the the crypto
currency
Center formerly Staples Center
and uh that's gonna be kind of cool how
that that thing's just going to be like
the curse of of uh the Lakers Clippers
Arena
you know like first it was Staples and
now Staples like there was a Staples
down the street for me that just [__]
closed I think they're all online now
cryptocurrency isn't that going belly up
I have no idea I don't wear a bow tie I
don't understand money
you know
you don't listen to somebody unless they
wear a bow tie when they're talking
about the economy
so um
yeah now it's called cryptocurrency so
you fly down you're following the 110
South when you cross the 10 you get on
with lax you make your radio call and
then you go right by
uh La Memorial Coliseum and that new
place where the soccer team plays that
used to be the site of the LA Sports
Arena and what I love about that little
patch of land there is the amount of
championships that were won and lost
the first two Super Bowls were played
when they were the NFL AFL championship
game at Memorial Coliseum in the LA
Sports Arena a lot of people don't know
this Bob cousy's last game with the
Boston Celtics they beat the LA Lakers
if you can believe this back in the day
the LA Lakers could never beat the
Celtics
could never beat the Celtics until uh
free agency the internet and horse
went all mainstream and then just Boston
as a city could not compete
we have cold weather and still too many
people in Boston sound like Nick Nolte
in 48 hours
so they choose to come to LA with all
the gorgeous women the sunshine
and where too many Nick Nolte looking
guys uh you know too many too many guys
sound like Nick Nolte in 48 hours
because I will say that forever La is
every bit is [__] racist as Boston
will ever be and I they just are known
for Sunshine in Hollywood like every
city just gets there
thing you know Boston can't shake
busting bossing compared to the Watts
Riots and Rodney King
you know if you looked at him in an
album sales kind of sense
I would say that those were much higher
I mean Rodney King that was like you
know that was on the level of like the
Eagles Greatest Hits as far as like the
coverage that got but still people do
not equate La as being This Racist place
um
I mean I know I don't I just get to
drive around being a white guy
sorry about all that dumb broad but I'm
gonna pull that with Nia I'm sorry about
all that
[__] [__] dumb broad [__] that I say
yeah you know that's just doing my job
just keeping you ladies down yeah well
that doesn't explain everything I know
it
Chinatown we're going to one two three
four how about the bus boys
new shoes
you think I didn't watch that movie and
re-download that for the nine millionth
[__] time every time I watch that
movie I download the Busboys [__] I want
to do the whole soundtrack but it
doesn't exist
on iTunes and that's that's who I
interact with that's who I I'd be
[__] with when it comes to that [__]
I'm not gonna have like a bunch of
different
you know the iPhone punishes you
when they're just like oh you're gonna
use it you're more than welcome to use
another streaming
uh platform for your music or whatever
the [__] you call it but the avatars
aren't going to show up and it's going
to be all weird and difficult
there's such [__] they really are like
the hot chick
you know like hey God who invented her
it's just some Android [__] oh my God
she's like so not cool
I'm like so not gonna [__] work with
you
on that last last iphone we had
Terry Robinson designed the
the new emojis it was Terry Robinson but
Steve Jobs gets all the credit
oh that'd be funny that the whole thing
would be Steve Jobs even though he's
dead oh he's still going to give him the
credit um it was his vision
and the new sleeker design that
unknown
smart people worked on in that round
building
outside of San Francisco will get no
credit and it's still uh we're still
going with Steve Jobs Steve Jobs is
going to get all the credit for that one
and on timpani was Steve Jobs
Steve Jobs nephew Steve's Stevie jobs Jr
the third Esquire
Bill Gates in the garage coming up with
the first home computer
um
all right let me do uh did we did I get
my reads yet
oh here we go oh oh here we go oh we
have no reads all I have is the live MMP
to um
to uh what do I what do you call it to
promote here the Monday Morning podcast
live I'm doing a live show
of the podcast uh here in La there's
only going to be like 100 tickets so if
you want to stream this thing
uh streaming tickets for the digital
experience
the Monday morning podcast live was
performed that was uh Bill Burr
on the microphone uh Bill Burr Andrew
themless was the podcast producer uh
tickets will be available for all Monday
Morning podcast listeners to take part
in the digital experience no matter
where in the world you call home April
23rd at noon Pacific Time Pacific
Standard Time 3 P.M Eastern Standard
Time 8 P.M British Standard Time 5 a.m
Australian Eastern Standard Time
that's when the [__]
it's going to be Statin around the world
uh I'm gonna be extra ignorant extra
stupid and all of that tickets are
available at
www.moment.com
that's
www.moment m-o-m-e-n-t dot Co slash Bill
Burr I'm sorry for all those [__] jokes
I just do a job
ah that was him
I mean what else you got to do go back
to jail
Chinatown yeah
listen I'm sorry I don't have the time
to hang out with you Jack
[__] you
yeah
that's the end of the podcast
um
not [__] on Nick Nolte I love Nick
Nolte
um it was just a time people that's one
another fun thing about going back and
watching old movies aside from the old
cars
the old music and all of that you just
see what was accepted and what wasn't
accepted and some of it makes you go
Jesus Christ and then other stuff's like
why did they stop doing that
I like that
like you know I know you know
I've heard all the stories and all that
and a lot of cool [__] you know uncool
[__] did happen but you know it was
great to go to a rated R movie knowing
you were going to see some titties just
selfishly just saying that
you know titties went away
laughs
titties were just [__] I'm telling
you man if you want to see titties 70s
and 80s there was just titties [__]
just falling out
everywhere didn't matter what century
Western out in space there was just wow
that's not true
well I didn't watch a lot of space
movies
were there titties in space space space
I don't remember
I don't remember out of Christ that was
that I didn't mean all of that space
titty [__] just doing my job
um
um I do love Nick Nolte's car
that he had he had like an early 60s
Cadillac and it was funny that was
considered a piece of [__] and nowadays
with all the uh
all these
guys that build cars on TV you know it
had a straight body
they would fix that thing up and make it
[__] Cherry dude and then Eddie's
character had that old Porsche a lot of
cool cars in that
I believe there's a Ford Fairmont
that Gans and Billy bear
kidnap uh Luther's girlfriend Elizabeth
Elizabeth you okay
um
I got hit
I don't believe it
I got shot
um
fire water is that what you meant I
gotta watch that again [__] great
movie anyway that's it everybody
um enjoy the baseball bat NBA and NHL
playoffs coming up it's a great time of
year this summer is coming I'm excited
I've been drinking coffee and reading
the [__] newspapers and uh Colorado's
had about enough of us taking their
water which is a great thing
um I think that'll finally Force LA to
capture all the water that they just let
go down the LA River
out into the ocean
I think it's gonna work but it's not
gonna work until rich people can't take
as long a shower
you know
at first it's going to be let them eat
cake
you know let them wash in the river
right but then eventually they're gonna
have to do something that's that's what
I'm predicting
slash I'm sort of freaking out
because I live here all right that's it
go [__] yourselves have a great weekend
you [__] and uh enjoy the music picked
out by the wonderful Andrew femalis and
we'll have a bonus episode of the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast following the
music that is it ah I gotta hit stop
here I never I never had to
why is it so difficult to do this it's
literally moving the opposite way
there we go
come on
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast from
Monday April 13th
2015.
you know Monday the 13th is not bad luck
it's Friday the 13th so [__] relax
because I said 13 all right before we
get all I do it you gotta rub the
[__] garlic and vinegar on your left
ass cheek
because the devil lives on the left side
if you're going to have a good day
all right let's get down to it I talked
a lot of [__]
I talked a lot of [__] oh [__] you you
Senator fans you know you actually know
why I've talked all that [__] because I
wasn't watching hockey
and all I saw I knew the Bruins would
want a couple because I follow him on my
little smartphone there
you know I follow the Bruins the
Canadians and the Kings the Bruins and
the Kings because I like them and the
Canadians because I hate them right and
I just always want to know what those
[__] blue Blanc a douche are doing
right I actually I like the team I just
hate their fans you know they don't
really know hockey they think they do
and they put on loafers and they they
whine I mean
no Canadian fan can ever say that they
know hockey when you watched your fan
base boo Patrick Wah out of town because
he had a bad regular season game
and uh that curse hangs over you which
is why you won't win it again this year
whatever stop being a [__] bill so any
reason why I talk [__] was because I
like everybody else saw that thing where
the Bruins were selling playoff tickets
so I thought they made it so I just you
know it was just being a douche and I
started giving the [__] Senators [__]
I didn't even know that's how bad a fan
I was this year
but uh but I stuck with them
and I kept talking [__] I hoped against
hope yesterday Bruins tied it up you
know to go into overtime and then they
[__] lost but um
I don't know
it's a lot of Bruins fans wow that
season was a [__] disgrace and blah
blah blah blah then other fans giving me
[__] partly it's because I talked all
that [__] but like I don't really
consider it a [__] disgrace you know
what I mean we're great franchise you
know we went to the playoffs 29 [__]
years in a row and then like another 10
years in a row and then another 10 years
something like that something we've
missed the playoffs like [__] three
times in my life
big [__] deal am I Really Gonna Be
Sad as a Boston fan
do you realize in the last four years we
won a Stanley Cup we won a World Series
in a Super Bowl all we need is the
[__] Celtics to pull their green and
white asses out of the mud and the next
couple years and we're gonna run the
table again and this is what kills me
we're doing this with four [__] teams
how can we do this with four teams and
then you look at the state in New York
that has 10 [__] teams
the state of California is like 15
[__] teams and collectively they
never have in a 10-year period run the
table and won all of them go ahead hit
pause look it up
look it up so I am fine
um I'm not as negative about the Bruins
as everybody I think we you know we got
some good young players or whatever the
guys that won the cup maybe got a little
bit old
you know what are you gonna do the [__]
are you gonna do all right so
congratulations
to all you people that have given me
[__] you know
especially Senator fan well I guess they
deserve to give me [__] because I talk
so much stuff but I'm just sitting there
thinking my head like dude you're a
[__] eighth say do you really think
you're gonna win a cup
you're not
all right so we'll we'll save a seat for
you down at the golf course for when you
swing by in May what do you think about
that I'm [__] with you I don't give a
[__] at this point my team's out of it
so good good luck to everybody except
for the Canadians
good luck to the Ranger fans
you know you guys won one cup in 75
[__] years I I'd be nice to see you
get another one even though you are fans
of New York teams and that's one of my
favorite [__] arguments that you
doubled down in every sport you know
it's like you're playing Blackjack and
every [__] hand you get dealt two
Aces and you still lose
ah Jesus Christ I'm [__] wiped up man
I stayed out last night till like I
don't know what I had I had some friends
come by
and we went to this uh this local bar
and uh I didn't even drink that much
it's just that I had a 4 30 pickup
for a 7 A.M flight and um
I don't know I stayed out till like
three I think I slept for like a [__]
hour and a half
and uh I got on the plane and I was
asleep and I vaguely remember them
saying we had mechanical problems had to
[__] taxi back to the gate I slept
through all of that everybody oh what
the [__] I'm [__] alone just gonna take
I slept through all of it and I didn't
wake up until we were over the [__]
desert which is perfect
um so it was actually was a great flight
but uh I got some [__] to do tomorrow so
I am recording this Sunday afternoon I
usually have a rule that I do not record
podcasts
um
you know on days that I fly because I'm
usually [__] I don't know it does
something to me I'll tell you it does
something funny you know
um so anyways I don't have a team to
root for at this point so you got to be
asking yourself Bill who the [__] are
you rooting for
in the playoffs
who am I rooting for
um I'm not gonna waste my time voting
for this rooting for the center this
would be great to see them win because
they've never won but I'm not going to
waste my time with that because uh you
know they're a [__] eighth seat all
right
there you go so that's done
okay I think it's going to come down to
uh probably Rangers and Canadians again
although so I figured they're the
favorites I'm gonna actually I'm gonna
in the East I'm gonna root for the
capitals I like the capitals I like
Ovechkin because he actually scores he's
a goal scorer but he's not he's not a
[__] like most goal scorers
you know they usually got some big guy
[__] skating right behind him you
know stay away from him stay or give him
his space you know
he's got a Mean Streak to his game he
actually plays a physical game
he has gold laces which I think is a
nice little piece of flair
I do have to say that guy I think that's
you know
hemataves of my two of my favorite guys
to watch like when I
but a vet can I know there's something
about the way that guy plays he's always
in the exact same spot in the offensive
zone he's just sitting there with his
stick up in the air waiting for a
[__] one timer
um
so I'm gonna root for those guys
especially if they wear their old school
uniforms that has to have the styes on
the sleeves I've always liked those so I
guess I'll root for those guys and
believe it or not as much as I [__] on
uh
New York which I just do because it's
fun you know I actually like the Giants
believe it or not even though they
kicked our ass twice in the Super Bowl
um well kicked our ass the first time
the second time we [__] blew it
um Brady the welcome doubt
um I actually
I'm actually a ranger fan even I was a
Bruins fan I shouldn't be because we had
a brutal brutal brutal [__] rivalry
in the 70s Brad Park was always whining
about Bobby Orr and how he got all that
attention he was [__] jealous you
know what I mean
um he was like the chick that wasn't
quite as hot and just sat there [__]
staring daggers at the prom queen all
through the 70s that was funny is he
ended up being a bruin and um but I was
I was too um I was too young to remember
that I just I don't know I always liked
the ranges I always liked the original
six teams
um
including the actually you know gotta
respect the Canadians you know what I
mean even though you know [__] 12 are
there cups they won
probably playing Outdoors on a frozen
River
[Laughter]
[Music]
we beat the Montreal Maroons in 12 best
12 out of [__] 27 or whatever the
[__] it was back then
um that math didn't work I know go [__]
yourself
um best 12 out of uh what would it be 12
out of 23.
right there you go because they had all
[__] day back then
um so anyways
I don't know I like the Kings I like the
Blackhawks
I like the blues I think I might roof
for the blues because the Kings have won
one I still like the Kings though
um
I don't know I like a lot of teams in
the West
except for Vancouver
although Vancouver's not Vancouver
anymore most of those guys left they
still got the Twins then they got
Burrows
that guy thank God for that guy he's the
reason why the Bruins won
[__] Vancouver was kicking her ass
and all of a sudden he just started
being a douche and it was just like wait
a minute that's what we do
[Laughter]
you're gonna bite somebody in the finger
come on man that's that's what the [__]
you want to play dirty Jesus Christ
that's a game
so anyways um I have no idea so I think
I'll actually I'll be watching the Kings
and then um
I actually like uh
the blues because they haven't won ever
and um
yeah that's what I'll do I'll probably
just be rooting for underdogs but either
way I am almost excited for the plants
even though we didn't [__] make it
what are you gonna do what do you might
be a [__] baby about it
congratulations to the Senators and I
look forward to sitting next to you
watching a game with you
uh very soon
as we sit there with both of our teams
not in the playoffs
um
all right so
I did uh I mentioned working in Tampa
and then Florida I was down on Miami
Beach which is [__] insane Miami
Beach really it puts Hollywood to shame
as far as uh beautiful women
uh train wrecks plastic surgery old guys
with younger women I mean it's just it's
unbelievable
um
and some of the most but I do have to
say some of those beautiful women I've
ever seen in my life so I did a couple
of shows at the Jackie Gleason Theater
and uh there's no [__] office that
they kept that was just like Jackie
Gleason's I forget who the [__] told me
that they don't they have obviously they
just have a green room like Yep this was
his green room and downstairs he he
actually had a bed and all that if he
got uh if he worked too hard wink wink
he would sleep here and uh
you know so he'd be here for the next
day to go to work or whatever but it was
still you know it was awesome to perform
there and afterwards we went to this uh
this after party
and um it was really cool I got to see
uh Chappelle because uh he was
performing at this theater the same
theater I should say a bunch of days
and uh got to tell you I was like I was
psyched to talk to him but when this
[__] really loud club
you know playing that that uh that music
that makes me feel old that computer
generated music and there was all these
[__] strobe lights and uh
I don't know it was just a bunch of [__]
going on and they had us in like this
roped off area and it was funny because
it was like nobody in the club so rather
than looking like this cool VIP area we
look like we had some sort of plague
they were trying to entertain us
with uh horrible music maybe slowly kill
us I don't know what but um
anyways I want to thank everybody that
uh that came out to the shows I had a I
had an awesome time so you know what's
coming up next everybody
oh the Billy Bible beltor That's the
next one
the next one
when the [__] do we start that I don't
even know can it says somebody tell me
how to get rid of this stupid updates
updates available on my computer and it
says install or my option is later
and my all I can say is trying an hour
try tonight remind me tomorrow turn on
auto update so just every [__] day I
gotta click on this thing I never update
iTunes is the only thing I update I
never update anything else because it
just fills up your [__] computer it's
like my computer works
you know what I mean I don't know I
don't understand what the problem is
here
um
I don't know I don't I never update my
phone I still have the iPhone 4S which
at this point it's starting to [__]
uh it's starting to wig out on me here a
little bit I'm gonna have to finally
give into it but uh
I haven't heard anybody [__] about the
six in a while so I guess it I guess the
the coast is clear and I can actually
buy one I always do that I always wait
for people to buy the phone [__] about
it and then they fix it and then I buy
the next one I draft behind you that's
what I do I'm like a coward in war
I sit in a [__] Foxhole in the fetal
position crying as you guys go over the
wall and take it in the face right
what is this thing doing
why is it blinking
just made a noise right am I still
recording I think I'm recording I don't
[__] know anyway so Billy Bible
beltor all right it starts April 18th in
Savannah Georgia
April 19th we're in Knoxville Tennessee
um the 20th Chattanooga Tennessee 21st
we are in uh Memphis 22nd Shreveport
thank you very much everybody for uh
helping me sell these tickets why does
this thing keep beeping
ah [__] I don't know I don't even know
if I'm [__] recording at this point
maybe I'm just doing it for me all right
the 23rd we're in New Orleans all right
we're in there and then we're there for
a couple of days and then we got
Huntsville Alabama
then we got all right I have to [__]
address why this thing is [__]
beeping what is the problem I have
battery power
right
why do you keep making that
all right the [__] thing was beeping
because the memory was full I swear to
God man I have no I have no instinct
when it comes to uh Electronics
technology any of this [__] I just
you know I I [__] idiot when it comes
to this stuff I like
I like old school [__] you know
anything pre like digital watch I didn't
have a problem with it it was simple you
put batteries in the back of it you know
you [__] wound the hands of the clock
you looked at the clock there it was
you just plugged it in
right isn't that what you did you wound
it up there you go I miss those I miss
those days nice and [__] simple
you know
Oh Billy simple town you know I'd like
to go back to that at some point
Jesus [__] Christ with all of this
goddamn [__] this [__] new recorded
it's just so many extra goddamn bells
and whistles on it
you know what's funny is they could have
just came out with the exact same one
and I would have used their other one
until it was dead
this is just for these [__] nerds
we're like oh dude if you heard that no
one you know what the no one does
the same as the old one except a couple
other things
oh I'm such a [__] when it comes to that
stuff I apologize
I apologize to what at all about that
[__] um anyways what the hell was I
talking about oh
I think I was listing the uh the dates
on the uh the upcoming tour I believe we
cut off at the 23rd I'm in New Orleans
Huntsville Alabama the 26th Jackson
Mississippi on the 27th Mobile Alabama
on the 28th Lexington Kentucky on the
30th in Evansville Indiana on the first
and then we go to the Kentucky Derby
what's great about this tour is I
haven't been to any of these [__]
places and
um so I'm going to be performing in
front of a bunch of people that have
never seen me before some never even
heard of me so uh you know it's weird
this is kind of like when I went through
Southeast Asia
except they're doing it my own country
so uh
it's gonna be a good time but I'll tell
you right now oh Billy's been in the
[__] gym
all right I've been doing the tens when
I'm on the road that workout bartneck
showed me is what you do 10 jumping
jacks 10 burpees 10 sit-ups 10 push-ups
10 like alternate leg lunges and then 10
jump squats and then you do nine
run through it again then you do eight
run through it again go all the way down
to one and then I skip rope for two or
three rounds and by the end of that I'm
[__] dead and I'll tell you right now
you do that I swear to God you can drink
a 12 pack and eat a [__] quarter
pounder with cheese and wake up with a
flat stomach all right there you go
that's what you need to do you know I
have a buddy of mine oh I got a friend
of mine you know
he's uh one of these [__] guys you
know he's always trying to lose weight
right
but he does like those fad diet things
you know
dude I've cut out all sugar you know I I
don't eat carbs not eating bread
not eating bread dude I cut out bread
all together it's just like how long is
that Gonna Last how can you
realistically
realistically not have a [__]
sandwich
that's you know what I mean it's like
people who try to quit eating bread
that's like me trying to quit alcohol
it's just it's not gonna happen like how
long can I realistically go
and just remain sober
and just
go through life
you know at some point you you really
you gotta you have to drink
and I'm I'm saying this to alcoholics
too all right
I think you guys are way off base with
your sobriety
okay you're missing the point in life
the point in life is every you know you
don't do it every day you just every
like you know like three days
you get so drunk and belligerent you you
hurt everyone around you that you love
and uh you maybe create a legal problem
for yourself and you know I know that
this is obvious to most of my listeners
but I just don't understand why people
go to AAA meetings
um no I'm joking I just [__]
all you got to do is just start your day
with your [__] oatmeal these [__]
idiots man sitting there dude I'm done
with Pickles
I'm not done with anything like I try
not to eat McDonald's but I know at some
point oh I know I'm gonna go in there
and you know what I'm gonna go in there
my heart's gonna be [__] racing with
excitement knowing that I'm doing
something bad and I'm gonna eat it and
second after I eat it I'm gonna feel
like [__] I know I
I know him but I'm not I'm despite that
it's [__] delicious when it's going
down
right
and I know I'm gonna [__] hate but
everybody just every once in a while
hey did you see somebody did the uh it
was great somebody did the final four
like the bracket thing the March Madness
brackets with uh fast food
and I can't tell you how disappointment
pointed I was
that McDonald's got knocked out in the
first round
I just thought it was completely
disrespectful you know this is this is
the this is they're like the Rose Bowl
of fast food these are the ones who they
started it all right
March mad let me look this up
and I guarantee you're gonna you're
gonna take it [__] personally
March Madness fast foods
images come on Bill were you able to
find it were you able to make computers
work for you
for once in your life ah jeez it's just
a bunch of [__] advertising up well
there it is
I found it holy [__] I can't believe it
all right visit the page
visit the page I click the button
nothing happens
the vein in my forehead starts to pulse
but McDonald's got McDonald's gets
knocked out in the first round give me a
[__] break
McDonald's they're like the Duke of fast
of fast food you know they're just
they're just gonna be in it at least to
the great eight
when you say
what's your favorite fast food
in and out gets [__] knocked out
that had to have been an upset right
ah this is birthday cake first pie you
know what [__] you internet I'm so
[__] why can't you just find the [__]
that I need ah go [__] yourself all
right it's over whatever yet again yet
again you know what I need to learn how
to do I need to learn to not just
[__] Wing this podcast and just
search for the [__] that I want first
have it and then riff about it instead
of getting you guys excited that I'm
actually going to complete a [__]
thought on here
all right tapping out of that not even
gracefully that was just a train wreck I
just fell out of the side of a [__]
moving car that's what just happened
okay we went around a corner I didn't
have my seat belt on the door opened up
and then that was it oh freckles right
off the side road rash all over the side
of his big forehead
um
so anyways I actually watched a a
documentary that I think it was on HBO
uh my lovely wife recorded it on uh
Frank Sinatra this two-part series and I
gotta tell you man it changed my life
a
one part of it and it's the part where
he makes his second comeback
like I guess he he was like the first
sort of uh
you know he was like the Justin Bieber
of back then when he when he first did
like the uh when he first started
singing he was a crooner and all the
chicks loved him and that type of stuff
and it's funny all the big bands were
like the [__] rock bands
back then Benny Goodman and Glenn Miller
and all them and they're looking like
who the [__] is this kid
you know with all these girls screaming
you know and uh and also he just speaks
to the quality of talent back then a
musicianship that like a guy of Frank
Sinatra's Talent was considered like uh
like a [__] boy band
um
granted he had all that stuff going on
back then right Miles Davis Charlie
Parker and all that type of [__]
but they had all this amazing footage
and he was in uh I think the Tommy
Dorsey band
and like all they're doing they're
talking about Frank and I'm looking at
the band and they got Buddy Rich on
drums they don't even bring it up
it's just was the level of talent it was
just it was [__] unreal like you
really had to know how to play back then
so anyways he had basically after he
dropped off you know after his crooning
thing was over people thought he was
finished and I think that like the whole
rock star thing but was basically he was
basically a rock star before Rock was
um
you know there was no history of of
anybody ever doing that so when he fell
off everybody thought he was finished so
when he made his comeback
as the singer of sad songs and lament
whatever the [__] they said it was
considered the greatest comeback in
Showbiz history
so that wasn't the part that scared me
what scared me was the second time
you know when he was into his 50s now
I think the first time he fell off it
was just like I don't know he's in like
his 20s he was considered older and
washed up or something or maybe like
into his 30s so 20 years after that he
has his second one and this is the one
that scared me and they said Frank was
making all these choices desperately
trying to remain relevant and they had
at one point he was singing with some
like Motown group and they had these
really like crazy like
like pimp suits meets like a Three
Musketeers kind of outfit right late 60s
crazy [__] and Frank puts on one of
these outfits to sing with this popular
group and he's got that big band swing
pulse and they're coming more with like
a Motown thing
and
I was literally on the edge of the couch
watching it with like my [__] head
and my hands going like oh my God this
happened to Frank Sinatra
like what the [__] is gonna happen to me
and I immediately
since then have been planning some sort
of I gotta have an exit strategy out of
this business
I've joked about it before on stage
saying how this business at some point
is finished with you whether you like it
or not but you never think about it all
you're thinking about is your next
project
um
you know it's this business is like a
fantasy it's not like the real world
where you're like I'm gonna do this
until then and then when I'm this age
I'm 65 I think I'm gonna retire and blah
blah blah blah like this business people
just [__] hang around and hang around
and hang around and hang around
to the point they [__] hire you when
people like when they go and they bring
up your name they go I thought he was is
he still alive
hey Sharon it's built
try find out if Bill Burr is still alive
like that'll [__] happen to me
someday if I stick around too long so
all I could you know what I felt like
when I was watching that
I felt like Paulie that scene in
Goodfellas
all right when he's talking to Henry
tell him to stay away from the drugs and
he talks about some other Dawn
he goes you hear about so and so he's
going to die in jail all right that
ain't [__] happening to me and I was
literally watching Frank wearing that
suit and that's all I could think
I can't say that's not going to happen I
just hope that does not happen to me
um I just started having these [__]
panic attacks and me coming out on stage
on a cruise ship with like a walker
and people just going to see me at that
point just to see me like hey you know
he's
come on
jokes for 40 years we got to go see this
guy and come out there old age spots on
the top of my [__] head
that desperately trying to cover up with
[__]
I don't know what kind of makeup you got
a goddamn sander electric sander he's
kick in the top of my [__] head
before I go out there
um
yeah [__] that I gotta I and I think I
know what I'm gonna do
this is what I'm gonna do I got to start
investing money outside of this business
so I have Inc I need mailbox money
coming in outside of this business so
whenever they're done with me I can just
transition you know what I think I'm
gonna I think I'm gonna become a slum
Lord
laughs
I'm gonna live this like dual life where
I'm gonna be this smiling Entertainer on
stage and I'll do benefits for diseases
and underprivileged people and all that
and then one day I will get exposed for
the monster I truly am and I'll have all
these [__]
like you'll be like stories about how
inexplicably like tuberculosis is coming
back
and eventually they'll trace it back
to this like these four awful towers of
apartments
that are owned by this uh this
Corporation they're like well who is
behind uh go [__] yourself Inc or
whatever
Billy redface who is Billy redface then
they'll [__]
they'll bust me
no that'll be the end of it now you know
what I'll blame I'll blame the uh the
Astra family
out of New York and I'll just be like
well I got I got my business model
through them I mean they did the same
thing and for some reason no one trashed
them and they actually got an entire
subway stop
and peace of New York like named after
him you know ask your place
why can't we have uh Billy's place
I'll do it in Detroit I'll go I'll go
there and I'll buy up a whole block
you know and then rather than redoing it
I'll rent it out to crackheads just you
know I'm just I'm just throwing [__]
against the wall here just just go easy
here with this uh this this business
model I ran it out to some crackheads
right and um
yeah it's a stupid idea they don't have
money all right so they have to get them
out of there
do you know you get crack it out of your
house you gotta go uh
you got you got a bright flashlight and
a garden hose
that's what you do and you just you just
and you don't have it on full blast you
just have it on like that you know when
you're when you're watering a dainty
flower in your garden you do you ever do
that
sitting out there you know
subconsciously scratching your ass
that's basically how you do it except
you hold one with like flashlight and
then you just sort of you water them
you know water's good for you that's
like their Kryptonite and they they get
out of there you treat them like house
cats they get up on the couch
you know you just keep doing that
so the hardest part is getting the water
turned back on while they're still in
there you know I don't know what the
[__] I'm talking about but anyway so I
watched that thing did anybody see it it
scared the [__] out of me this whole
[__] thing of getting old and not
being [__] relevant and all of that
type of stuff and uh
I don't know desperately trying to
figure out where the [__] do you go
where do you turn to
you know what I mean this is why I like
not having kids is [__] scary because
then you know that you can lean back on
your kids like well they'll take care of
me you know at least they'll stick me in
a [__] home or something I can eat
applesauce
as I yell at the wall am I sitting in my
own [__] feces right I mean
wait till it rains and I stick my old
ass out the window and I wash it off
Jesus Bill oh you know whatever go [__]
yourself it scared me I got a little
scared so I'm thinking of being a uh I
think I'm going to become a slum Lord on
the side
so I'll let you know if uh I can find an
apartment building that cost about I
don't know about seven eight grand
and go down to Home Depot put some
[__] uh PCP [__] pipe in a PCV
piping whatever [__] it's got oh it's
called
that's what I'll do
I'll be a monster
on the side while I smile and wave at
benefits that is my exit strategy so
this is my question for you guys you
guys in the real world
all right because I'm I'm not even
joking about how frightening that was to
watch what what is uh what is your exit
strategy if you have a career right now
all right and if you do have children do
you think that you have raised your
children
in a way that they are both smart enough
to have a career where the it where they
can take care of you
and secondly where were you nice enough
to them that they don't hate your
[__] guts that they don't give a [__]
you know
you know they don't care if you're rot
in a [__] old folks home were you
nice enough to them that they don't
resent you or were you not selfish
enough that they picked up on your
selfish habits and they're like yeah I
don't give a [__] about my dad or my mom
you know that's what I'm asking I'm
asking the tough questions here
all right let's read some of the [__]
advertising here for this week
um
all right the Thursday afternoon Monday
Morning podcast okay Bill
in case the rest of the morons who
listen to your podcast haven't extended
a thank you yet let me do so on behalf
of them for the Thursday afternoon
Monday Morning podcast that comes in
just before Friday there I love the
music between the old clips especially
last week's my wife and I were listening
on the way to work and she pointed out
that you sound different on Thursdays
Monday you come out of the gate and by
Thursday you see more at peace it's
probably too early to claim a pattern
but we'll see anyways thank you again
ah Jesus Christ can women ever just
[__] not be trying to figure what
figure you out they're [__] weird
sorry I needed a drink there you know he
seems more I like the Thursday bill
like just like and you know what and
they always act like what they're trying
to do is to make your life better and
all she's doing she's like they're
constantly gaining
like uh reconnaissance like information
you know what I mean because generally
speaking unless you you're dating one of
those UFC chicks you know what I mean
they can't beat the [__] out of you so
they gotta go cerebral so they are
constantly
on some sort of surveillance Mission
even on a guy that isn't in their
[__] lives
it just weirded me out that she's
listening to it at that level
and you know what's funny she just does
it naturally
who the [__] else would be thinking that
he seems more um
Melancholy on Wednesdays but on
Saturdays there's a light there's a
light at the end of the tunnel
no Jesus Christ maybe because Mondays
I'm flying back from somewhere and I'm
hungover how about that maybe that's
what it is
but I'll tell you right now I'm never
more at peace
um I'm actually happy somebody would
ever think that they heard that in my
voice
all right I'm going to read this next
one
I'm going to read it in my I guess my
Thursday let me try to get myself more
at peace here
need advice
hey
Billy [__] tits
I need your help
my girlfriend of three years has been
acting really strangely lately
things were fine up until two months ago
we were banging and hanging all the time
without I can't do this we were banging
and hanging oh Jesus you high-fiving
while you were [__] too all the time
laughs
hey I'm gonna come up top bro up top
up top bro Jesus
[__] Switcheroo there huh um
we were banging and hanging all the time
without any problems at all except for
the odd fight over which restaurant to
go to life was pretty sweet anyways
lately she's never been available
between 7 pm and 10 p.m and when I do
reach her after 10 p.m she's really
grumpy and doesn't want to talk to me
she tells me it's not me and not to
worry it'll be better soon but she's
been like this for the last two months
and there's no end in sight she's also
keeps canceling our plans at the last
minute saying she's not feeling up to
going out she's never acted like this
before and we've known each other for
seven years oh Jesus a seven year Rich
there
[Music]
um
anyways yesterday was the breaking point
I called her around 9 30 p.m and she
told me to go [__] myself and hung up on
me I called her back 45 minutes later
and I'll be honest I was crying a little
oh God she's in your heart now dude well
seven years she's gonna be uh what was
different was that this time she was
crying too and she said she was really
sorry and that the last two months oh
[__] you I'm not even gonna read that
come on man hey Andrew quit sending me
the [__] troll ones
all right election uh I mean I gotta
read it because it was funny but I mean
I don't want to turn all of these
questions into everything and wow it was
just a joke because then I don't have
anything to [__] tie there was she
had been watching the Bruins and blah
blah blah blah
basically if that was a real one she
would have been crying the entire season
uh yeah don't send me these things
because this is what helps me talk for a
[__] half hour if every one of these
is going to be like oh I [__] trolled
you yeah
you know
anyways election dear Capitol Hill bill
can we get your thoughts on the 2016
election Hillary Ron Paul or Rand Paul
Ted Cruz
uh thoughts on any of them or what
direction you think this country is
going in
um
I think Hillary's got a great shot
because she's a woman
and there'll be a big pressure to not
say she stinks because you'll get
branded as a sexist
um
I'm sick of the Clinton family and the
Bush family I I just I need a fresh face
to be lying to me that's the one thing
I've Loved about Obama
over the last eight years at least it
was a different face you know just
shoveling a bunch of [__] at me as
opposed to just [__] I mean can we
just get out of the [__]
Bush Clinton Bush Clinton I don't want
to do that you know
I really don't and also when a woman
becomes president it's gonna it's gonna
crush me
to watch how excited women are going to
be as if it's going to make a bit of
[__] difference
and I don't mean that in some hateful
way towards women I just can't stand
people who [__] honestly look at the
presidential
office as if that person can can do
anything
you know this is gonna get this is going
to get [__] dark here
I think it's all [__] when you look
at what [__]
politicians make
it's pathetic
it's pathetic what they make 400 Grand
to be president you get 200 something
Grand to be a goddamn senator all right
and all of those offices cost millions
and millions and millions and millions
of [__] dollars to get so you have to
go to all these other [__] guys and
then you owe all of them favors so
you're bought and paid for before you
even get into the [__] office and
then what happens is afterwards somehow
like like something ridiculous like 65
to 70 percent of of senators are
multi-millionaires it's like how the
[__] did you do that
if you just made a couple hundred grand
a year because you're going to get
whacked in half in taxes
you know what I mean I just think the
whole [__] thing is corrupt and um
look at Obama the first African-American
president you would think that they
would be so that should have been the
most liberal [__] guy ever and he
wasn't it was just to me it was just
more of the same more the [__] same
more of the uh ooh these people are
gonna get us more of that [__] and just
getting everybody to hate everybody all
around the [__] world it's just been
all of that same exact [__]
and I don't think
you know any of those guys I don't know
if
who's who's you know the woman that I do
like is the one who's [__] actually
calling out the banks and saying we need
to break up the Monopoly that's the one
that I like out of everybody that I've
heard talk she's the one that I'm
actually like wow she's actually saying
something
you know
um
but I mean if she actually tried to do
that she would get whacked and I totally
believe that she would she get I don't
know that they even have to [__]
whack it now they can just they'll just
destroy you if I don't know they'll go
through your emails and they'll kill you
that way but uh that's that's what
that's what I feel and all that I think
it's uh I think it's hopeless and
um yeah we're gonna [__] it all up in
the world at some point will be
unlivable because it'll be so polluted
and overpopulated and then we'll
basically I know something will happen a
volcano or merciful asteroid and uh
that's those are my beliefs so there you
go
hey maybe that woman was right that I I
am more at peace and hopeful on Thursday
re-asked me that on Thursday and I'll be
like you know what I think Hillary is
wonderful
it would be so great for women
everywhere and Men
all right thoughts on Pete Rose
hey Bill big fan
I know you're very passionate about
sports was curious where you stood on
Pete Rose with All-Star Game in
Cincinnati this year now if ever would
be the time to get for him to get
reinstated now that you've got podcast
twice a week thought you might have time
to rant about Pete Rose sometime check
out the link below if you have a minute
song I wrote put Rose in the Hall of
Fame love you brother
um
I don't know you know
I think when you [__] up like he did I
mean that's the number one thing you're
not supposed to do you're not supposed
to uh Gamble on baseball because that
[__] with the the uh the Integrity of
the game Beyond like even like steroids
um
because then you're literally like
trying to lose a game possibly which at
least with steroids you're trying to
[__] win at least you're trying to
[__] win and I know he says I never
bet against my team but I mean I don't
know if anybody knows a [__]
degenerate Gambler I mean eventually you
know
you get yourself into situations and you
need that one big score and there's 162
games hey
why don't I bring that guy up from AAA
and put him on the mound see what
happens
um
at the last second of course
um I wouldn't mind if they Point him in
at this point I feel like he he paid the
price but I had no sympathy for the guy
uh
you know for the first like 20 years of
this [__] but um at this point he's an
old man just put him in there I mean the
guy he was so great for baseball uh it's
just unfortunate that he had that
problem and um I think he paid the price
I'd let him back in there you go huh
there's a little Thursday attitude for
you
wasn't that nice
I almost had a little tear in my eye
um
all right where are we going here uh
Daredevil
Jesus Christ Daredevil dear Wonder bill
you don't strike me as much of a comic
book fan yeah I liked him when I was a
little kid
you know oh boy do you think Aquaman
could beat Electric Man what about the
gas burner
um
but you should really check out the new
daredevil show on Netflix the fighting
is great uh he gets his ass kicked which
adds to the reality of one guy walking
into a room and facing seven others
Vincent D'Onofrio all right I'm already
in Rosario Dawson all right I'm in one
of the hot chicks from True Blood is in
it it's dark as hell please report back
with the review uh are you caught up on
the following I never saw the following
um I'm trying to find where the [__] I
can watch the pilots A Better Call Saul
they don't have it as far as I can tell
up on AMC if anybody can find me that in
like the first two episodes I have the
rest of the season taped episode three
through the finale I have to do that
first and then I'm going to go to
Daredevil I really want to get into Lord
of the Rings but I just hate [__]
period pieces with the [__]
I just hate the clothes
you know what I mean they're walking
around in those castles with no Central
Heating and nobody is ever shivering I
just can't get into it
um all right
what is the following
what is the following what the [__] is
that that is that it better not be a
werewolf zombie or vampire thing
if I had to guess the following is that
about somebody who starts at church
is that what it is come on old computer
you can do it
this is how long it takes my [__]
computer my goddamn neighborhood
because we won't have one of those fake
Internet trees
because it'll muscle the Integrity of
the Aesthetics
the following the following uh watch the
most current episode on Hulu The
Following TV series a brilliant and
charismatic yet psychotic serial killer
communicates with other active serial
killers how the [__] have I not been
watching this
this is tremendous
and Advocates a cult of Believers
following his every command
all right so what they did was they took
the Charlie Manson thing and they they
added a little little
a little extra thing to it he used to
have to stand in front of them now these
he can do whatever the [__] he wants
yeah all right I'm in
dude can I there's never been another
time
in the history of Television where
there's been this many unbelievable
shows to watch like it's insane
I don't get why a TV show is so [__]
great
and it's so hard to find a good movie
now
you know I mean people steal TV shows
too I'm starting to think movies don't
have an excuse anymore everything
doesn't have to be a [__]
100 million dollar uh
I don't know you know I actually did see
a great movie I don't know if I brought
this up did anybody see uh
um wild Tales is the name of it it was
um a movie made by some
director out of uh Argentina it's
[__] phenomenal it's like six back to
back stories
um almost it kind of seems like like a
format like a Tarantino type of thing
that he would do but they're unrelated
but there's a a overall theme of this
really dark comedy uh revenge and that
type of stuff and it's um
me and Ian saw it the other day we
absolutely [__] loved it
um called wild Tales
um
definitely definitely check it out man
it was it was um
I don't know I'll tell you it was a
great movie you know all right a great
book bill I am reading this book
um called men on strike why are why men
are boycotting marriage fatherhood in
the American dream and why it matters oh
Jesus dude
why would you abandon all of that it is
it is a very in-depth look at the lack
of paternal rights and laws in this
country I've been talking to a lot of
younger guys in the military about it
so they don't get caught up
um yeah but what they should have is on
on is the back end of that like okay so
if you're never going to get married and
you're never going to become a dad
and have the picket fence and all that
you what you need to do is you need to
go hang out with some old Playboys who
are in their 50s
early 60s
and you will see a a sadness in their
eyes that you do not want your soul I
will tell you that because as much
you know as much as I go off and make
fun of women and everything you know I
am 10 times harder to live with
you know
so I mean they're they're tortured by us
too but I really can tell you that going
solo
is not the way
for most people I would think I mean
some people are just wired that way I
mean I have a little bit of that like I
am a big time Big Time
loner I get this weird thing where I
won't shut the [__] up when I'm with my
friends but like anytime we have like
company and [__] I swear to God
I swear to God like I I can only do it
for like eight to ten minutes and all of
a sudden I just have to get up and
walk out be by myself
sit outside in the porch just staring at
a tree it's really [__] weird
um
unless
maybe I'm just selfish unless the
subject is something that I'm interested
in what everybody's talking about I
gotta whisper this [__] my wife hears
this she's gonna be pissed oh great Bill
and then post it like she's not gonna
find out about it
um
no I just my brain just shuts down
that's basically what happens
and it's something he has said about me
a long time ago she goes you just
if you don't give a [__] about something
you just stop listening and it's really
annoying
and it's like all right well I thought I
was listening to my inner voice
[Laughter]
you know
I mean what what the footy
I am I am I am always amazed at people
that have really good social
Graces you know what I mean they come in
they know how to throw a party make sure
everybody's comfortable they notice that
somebody's drink is empty and all of
that I just I just like hey how you
doing all right poses over there
see you later don't talk don't talk you
know I come more with that vibe
not gonna tell you right now the second
I'm done uploading this [__] thing
like uh
I am I don't know I'm just gonna go sit
on my porch
staring at a tree
thinking nothing
I don't know I think I'm probably slowly
losing my [__] mind who knows um all
right let me read the last mercifully
read the last couple of these
live reads clicking on this
scrolling down
legalism these guys their copy is always
so [__] intense
I actually have to confess to stamps.com
I went to the post office the other day
you know what it was
um I just wanted some colorful stamps
every once in a while you know I want
some nice stamps
and I got these I got these I stood in
line
and it was a [__] show and it was every
reason why I don't like going down there
and I came up in line and of course I
was the next in line and then the
[__] person hit puts the next window
sign there it really should just say go
[__] yourself and then point a different
direction so I get Battle of New Orleans
the War of 1812 stamps which I think are
pretty cool and then I got these crazy
circus ones and I hate the circus
you got a bunch of scary clowns there's
a tiger and an elephant which you know
were abused
um
I don't know why I'm telling you this
and then I got a bunch that had flowers
on them they usually have some cool [__]
though they have like you know race cars
and [__] like that you know what I mean
what are you [__] eight years old
well hey you know what I'm a big kid go
[__] yourself I enjoy that type of stuff
anyways um
this is the this is the deal for this
week man the biggest thing in my life
here is this bus tour coming up and I
gotta tell you uh I'm so [__] excited
to be going to these cities because I've
never been there and I'm gonna be in
front of a bunch of people that I
haven't had the opportunity to to
perform in front of and their Vibe I'm
never gonna I'm it's gonna be a new
experience
you know when you get out of your
comfort zone and there's going to be a
lot of [__] that I'm gonna say that
they're gonna take maybe in a different
way which will cause other things to
happen it's going to be it's gonna be so
much fun and I'm gonna not understand
what they're saying sometimes the other
way around it's the [__] greatest and
uh it's gonna be me Paul verzi and Jason
lawhead and uh I can't wait so please if
you're in the area please come out tell
your friends about it and uh we'll give
you a great show and with that that is
the podcast for this week so once again
congratulations to the Senators you guys
deserve that you were the better [__]
team congratulations to the Penguins
the [__] Penguins
um
Rangers even the Canadians
congratulations all you guys I hope you
guys whatever I'm not going to be a [__]
about this all right good luck to all
you
I hope all your dreams come true even
though it will only happen for one fan
base
um
so I'm rooting for the capitals
and uh I've kind of become a Kings fan I
gotta admit it but uh I will also be
rooting for the Blues
um just because they haven't won it I
don't even know are the predators in it
a root for something like that then the
Jets they haven't won it
I don't know who gives a [__]